do you guys want a bt a calendar so i
launched the BTA program just over a
month ago it has some great results I
love you guys posting your BTA numbers
if you guys don't know what I'm talking
about Christina let's link up that video
to show them and one of the things that
that I've seen is people are having a
hard time keeping track of the number i
see a lot of you guys posting BGA 16 i
think i forgot where I was i don't know
i'm going to start all over and I get it
as frustrating and Nina like what we do
is we have a notepad file that everyday
kind of update to say where we're going
and I just got out of a meeting with
YouTube that's YouTube's headquarters
behind me see my official visitor badge
there and there may be some tools that
they're coming out with but it's going
to take a long time and one of the
things that I thought of was what about
a calendar would you guys want a monthly
principal calendar that you could put up
on the wall and X off and keep track of
what number you're at and also make the
calendar itself something that is
inspiring it has a famous entrepreneur
on there a quote on there something that
you can look to every day to get
motivated to get excited as well as keep
track of the number that you're at so
let me know what you think if you like
that idea and if you do what would be on
the calendar I want something that could
be easily printed out and something that
is inspiring that you want to look at
you want to have on your desk that you
want to engage with and it and visual
cues are a huge point in terms of
getting people to to follow up with
habits so if you're writing stuff down
on a piece of paper every day you're
much more likely to follow through on
that goal then if you're not and so let
me think of the idea let me know what
ideas you have to make that one page
you're amazing for each month and if you
guys like it then we'll make it we'll
see what you can do so leave it in
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon